I'd be all for like shaving a mohawk
right now I neither be finite I want to
have a Jeff Bridges beard
that is badass like properly put on
makeup I'll do a little something every
now and again just to make myself feel
more yeah together with my sweatpants
but this is this is all for you ET
online Aaron Chris Kevin it is so good
to see your faces the last time I saw
you my goodness I would have hugged you
a little longer if I had known but this
is what our world was gonna turn into
how are you guys doing I am considering
I mean a lot of people have it a lot
worse so counting blessings and feeling
grateful to have a comfortable place to
knock down just uh you know trying to
take up some new new hobbies I'm trying
to grow a bunch of vegetables right now
that's going on right oh my god okay we
will get into that I want to know about
this this regal garden that you're
sprouting apparently Kevin how you doing
I'm just this living isolation like I'm
eating a lot more which is nice aren't
we all sleeping more I try to be more
productive but then you know I don't
know like from a few minutes I'm
learning I'm trying to learn the piano
like properly yeah okay cool I want to
get into all these fun hobbies and
things that you guys have been picking
up but first of all can you tell us like
where you're holed up and and maybe who
you're with I am in Los Angeles and an
apartment in my little living room right
now yep okay Chris Vancouver with my
partner and our two dogs and my planets
good so you're in good company you're
hanging with where are you curly I'm two
miles underground in a bunker just oh
trying to really protect myself
Oh internet' --then yeah yeah is like
yeah no I'm I'm I'm renting a house in
in Toronto right now
I was kind of looking to do a house
shopping but that got put on hold so I'm
gonna in somebody else's house renting
it for a little while until this is all
over okay as long as it's comfortable
that's all them and you're safe
oh yeah great okay so quarantine is
really bringing out everyone's
creativity and new skills are blossoming
I want to know what are you guys doing
to pass these really long days at home
they think of I really quickly actually
do this that's my experience yeah tell
me why what are you doing because you
get up at 3:00 in the afternoon maybe
something to do with this I'm asleep
right now I get up and and you know walk
the dogs check on the plants in the
garden and then I kind of I don't know
what I do for about five hours and then
it's happy hour making your famous
margaritas at home I hope mm-hmm yeah
among other things
okay so mention you're really into your
garden what is going on what are you
growing I'm trying to grow tomatoes
peppers radishes carrots beets lettuce
kale onions zucchini peas yeah Liv I'm
just experimenting about a bunch of dirt
and some seeds that started when
quarantine started or did you kind of
have a green thumb before all of this
well I've never grown vegetables before
but I do love plants so um yeah I like
taking care of indoor plants I just
hadn't really experimented much with
with outside so if this presented a good
opportunity and I feel like it's a lot
more complicated than growing inside
okay luckily there's YouTube and lots of
helpful people out there on the internet
doing that okay so you're good at advice
uh have you has anything sprouted have
you been able to like me their progress
eaten anything I know I haven't eaten
anything yet but the radishes will be
done in two weeks or something so
they'll be the first ones and yeah yeah
everything else I think we'll have to
have to wait a little while Randy you
know they're this big it's very exciting
I check on them every hour and a half
it's like watching a kettle boil
well that's very exciting you'll have to
keep it on the progress take some
pictures and post them on Instagram
maybe you can send us some produce if
you're feeling generous sure uh Darrin
we were really blessed to have a glimpse
inside your kitchen I think it was my
highlight of quarantine Chris Kevin have
you guys seen herons brownie baking
video do it don't just all right I have
these videos yeah this is something like
this yeah watch it do yourself a favor
and watch it it has been truly the
highlight of my quarantine and it has
made me laugh and giggle and provided me
with so much joy prove myself Erin what
are you doing at home are you are you
baking a lot more than we've seen
developing any skills I've I've put the
baking on hold moment that was a bit of
a blow to the ego so I'll circle back
I'll get back on the horse I just need a
minute to find my confidence again as
you eloquently said mistakes are how you
learn that's true
don't forget it okay but I have been
doing other things like reading a lot a
lot of zoom game nights with friends and
family and actually I've been trying to
find a karaoke song which sounds really
lame but it's happened so many times
once or twice with these guys actually
where yeah wait a second so this never
happens again where you can put on the
spot you don't have a kitty egg you'll
have something next time to go I'm
experiencing I I would like to be
prepared by the time I come out of
lockdown what do you have it narrowed
down to can we help you
no I just really I need to work on this
privately
okay let me do let me ask are you more
of like a pop leaning girl or are you
more of like a classics kind of girl I
feel like I'm trying to go in a slightly
unexpected direction I'm actually toying
with a couple country songs right now
it's just wow you know I've bought a
bunch of dirt and I'm experimenting
[Laughter]
maybe one day I'll put you on the spot
and ask you to sing us a little
something good no no I really don't but
I'm sure you'd be happy to sing us a
little something from I bought a bunch
of dirt I'm just experimenting this is
the thought never saying yeah that's
that's the theme of the song drops great
you start that's pretty good
uh no it's not like if I was practicing
and maybe you know that's what I was
doing in isolation that I feel more
confident going into that but no I just
I I like playing AI II rented piano
before everything collapsed so I was
able to just kind of play around I'm
just trying to get better at it and I
have motorcycles so I go in a few like
isolation rides every now and then which
is kind of nice to kind of get another
city been making a lot of toast actually
no I've been getting better at it
there's something in Canada maybe for
America's you call good food where that
shows up there like a box it shows up
and it's like the ingredients for how to
make a bunch of meals it's like a miso
chicken thing that's really nice like a
vegetarian pasta dish you know I am I'm
just like get it in my belly as quickly
as I can I don't have time to read what
I'm eating beautifully no no it doesn't
matter Kevin you still can appreciate
and get joy from sure I'll try it
I'll try a few would they say on the
cookie show you eat with your eyes first
Kevin oh did they say that we were too
busy winning Chris we'd have time to
listen to well you know in the cookie
corner I guess I had plenty of time to
yeah oh sure I missed that part
apparently I can't read I know you've
been having fun and you've been you know
creative and channeling you know the the
joys in life but has there been anything
that's been really challenging about
this time yeah I mean absolutely
certainly high on the list is hearing
all the stories from around the world
that are just they're very sad and hard
to hear and so that's emotional and you
know on a more personal note feeling
like my grandparents are far away and
everybody's got to stay pretty isolated
and so that's hard and then I just kind
of Miss being able to get out in nature
I think that's something that I'm
realizing now fueled me even more than I
realized so I have low moments
absolutely but there's a lot there's a
lot to distract me like what
like the karaoke search yeah Chris how
you doing what's challenging for you
I think the isolation is are not just
just not being able to see your friends
and your family you know yeah my parents
my brother and my sister and I also I
love I really love food and I'm a big
foodie so I love going out to
restaurants and I just I miss the idea
of just being able to go meet up with
some friends have a nice dinner and some
wine yeah yeah yeah I'd say that the
simple things mmm Kevin yeah I think my
guruvar saying - I'm on a personal level
it's tough not to see my family or
friends I mean that's talk but on
another thing is it's it's tough not to
be able to do anything you know like
it's it's you want to help or like
volunteer so my deputies just they just
tell you to stay inside and like you
know you're doing more by not
essentially writing something yeah yeah
like it
it's his weird feeling of life but I
could be doing something you know you
just you know and recently just this
overshadowing so many things are
happening
Canada's going through another tragedy
right now that happened in Nova Scotia
and like it's it's almost like making
second page news to what's happening
with this Koba 19 stuff that it's sad
that you know where our focus can't be
where I think it should be sometimes but
yeah I think just this helpless feeling
is is the biggest thing I'm struggling
with for sure well I mean I know it's
hard because you all are such good
people and I know you intrinsically just
want to go out and help and do what you
can I don't know if you've been keeping
up with a whole lot of entertainment
news but a lot of casts have been
getting together they've been doing like
virtual table reads or open
conversations where fans can log in and
watch have there been any conversations
about doing something like that together
whether it's just to bring joy to your
viewers and your audience or two maybe
even raise money for charity that's a
really good yeah I mean we'll have to
get cracking on that we don't really
have any plans for it right now but I'm
sure we should have come together as a
cast and brainstorm there was if there
was an interest in something like that
to raise money figure out where the
money would go if was a food bank or if
it could go into you know the protective
PPE protective layers yeah
personal particular woman yeah something
like that it would be amazing yeah I
would I would love to be a part of that
yeah me too okay good we're gonna I'm
gonna thanks for the idea
oh yeah go harass the hallmark PPR team
to like it is great I speak on behalf of
all Hardy's I think people would love to
tune in and watch something like that
great I have a few like fun rapid-fire
questions for you guys I want to know
what shows are you binging just I mean
day
he's passed within the blink of an eye
on those two shows in the last time I
was with you we had a really good
conversation about all the like
oscar-winning films that we did recently
for you to sit here and tell me that
you're really into tiger King and love
is blind Oh shots me a little bit but
could you not be I mean tiger king by
the this sixth episode and you know the
next giant crazy thing that you it's all
washed away I mean can I tie a Carol
basket come on
hey oh you cool cats and kittens enjoy
exotic you know I just I remember seeing
his ad when he was running for president
like four years ago and I was like who
is this guy
and then you know when she comes up and
then of course love is blind was just
the first episode that guys crying I
mean there is scenery loves her and Nick
Lachey and his wife they did just like
disappear for four episodes there's a
hosts like where did they go and then
I've seen one episode of this this other
one too hot to handle or something one
of the best things about that is I see
artistically on unorthodox it was oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah did you do it in one
sitting
no I can't do anything in one sitting I
guess I don't know I need to like get up
and move in between each you be better
Kevin be better I feel like binging an
entire season of a show and one sitting
is a very crisp thing to do where you're
up until 4:00 a.m. and one of my
favorite things I get so much joy out of
watching an entire season in one go and
unorthodox was a breeze because it's
only four episodes no problem Oh Lucas
they really couldn't be more different
different styles Aaron what have you
been watching or or or movies or TV I
have been trying to balance the mindless
with things but I also binge - love is
blind
so that was fun and I've started
watching the new bachelor show listen to
your heart
got the most ownin watched the new Pixar
movie onward that was I got me right in
the feels and the new Emma was really
good and all four loved and Orthodox and
then I started this new HBO show called
run oh yeah I heard that yeah I was
really cool
Chris anything to add their unorthodox I
thought was insane that that that actor
each she's just like an absolute
powerhouse so yes she blew me away that
was amazing and then we've been watching
well I'm a little slow a little behind
so we haven't seen flee back yet so we
all started that I've seen a couple
episodes awesome so much fun yeah the
second season it's so good oh yeah okay
great so it's just gonna get better
why it really does yeah I'm enjoying it
when I Larry when the hot priest when
the hot priest gets there it's so good
isn't he on on our show the hot priest
oh I now pronounce you husband and wife
we may kiss your bride has there been a
live in outfits pres been getting
dressed or are we living in cozy sweats
I get dressed every day do you like you
put on jeans or like a proper pair of
pants yeah my girlfriend makes fun of me
for wearing jeans all the time say why
are you just in sweatpants because these
are my cozy pants my jeans are my cozy I
don't know yeah can't imagine having
like tight cool jeans on every day well
I'm just laying around the house it's
hard to be me okay good stay true to who
you are Kevin are you getting dressed in
the morning or you staying mom I'm in
the middle you know those days Cologne
on going into the living room the other
day it gets it's I need to remember what
this feels like to like you know get
dressed up and go out like you know play
it by ear
I'm feeling it up okay miss Erin I mean
I'm like I'm wearing a button-down shirt
but I'm fully in sweatpants right now oh
wow you did this stand up nobody stands
up on zero Wow yeah it's been it's been
sweatpants pretty much every minute of
every day and you've got like your
daytime sweats and then your nighttime
sweats it's just a whole rotation it was
getting dangerous when I was just waking
up in sweatpants and then kind of
spending the whole day in that outfit so
in order to kind of like yeah like you
said Kevin like to feel like myself
again it was like okay we got to start
somewhat of a routine here going on a
little longer than we all thought it
would yes um Erin I guess this is more
for you but guys feel free to chime in
how are you doing with beauty right now
have you done anything DIY are you
really excited to see a certain
beautician that you that you go to how
is it cuz quarantine
MLE I think I texted the guys this more
anything like I can't believe I'm
putting mascara on right now like
properly put on makeup during this whole
thing properly yeah I mean I'll do a
little something every now and again
just to make myself feel warm yeah
together with my sweatpants but this is
this is all for you ET online no DIY
beauty things to speak of I'm not even
sure what that means like crushing it
can mean anything anyone that's
something you've been doing like acid
rinses in their hair or they're putting
avocado on their face I mean Hilary Duff
I don't know if you follow her she dyed
her hair full-on bright blue guys I
don't know if you follow Armie Hammer
armie hammer delivered a quarantine look
for the ages I highly recommend you go
check out his Instagram he's gotta be
boo the most ridiculous mustache the
most insane mohawk it was like you know
I'm so used to seeing him in a suit and
looking all you know dapper and whatnot
and to see him sort of do his best Joe
exotic it was a truth I'm not Jim exotic
Inge but I'm trying to do the mustache
like I'm trying to go for something here
and grow a point so that's my hand
that's good you've got it like a dark
canyon thing going on any anything for
Chris Kevin have you guys tried anything
are you gone for a specific look here
I'm going for castaway
I'd be all for like shaving a mohawk
right now I think that'd be fun I think
it might interfere you know with the
future of my career but I I would be up
for hey if we're if we're in quarantine
long enough I think we got to hold you
to that I say my husband's head it's
already like grown back guys hair grows
so fast
mm-hmm you say that but I'm like knock
on wood because I'd be afraid
hey lady door says gonna come back it's
been a year I got it I have to tell you
when we when we had the wedding when
calls the heart cast put together their
little quarantine diary for us Aaron
buckles is answer on what he was trying
to accomplish was he wants to grow
facial hair and he specifically
mentioned Chris and Kay oh yeah maybe
one day I'll be able to grow a luscious
full beard like my co-stars Crispin Ali
in Kevin McGarry yeah feather duster
that he had as a mustache on that thing
that was a I wonder I hope it's come in
since well we'll have to touch base with
him and see how it's going but I thought
in the music
did you guys reveal the secret maybe
give away the secret sauce so maybe Erin
could you know try to replicate it do
you put any oil in a ketchup ketchup I
could see some of it right the sugars in
ketchup actually it allows your facial
hair to grow faster yeah I'm totally
kidding but if Erin buckles decides to
put ketchup in a space that I don't know
I just I'm actually I am envious of
folks who have like Mike my sides are
quite then um we watched what do we
watch the other night it was it was iron
man might have in the first iron man and
Jeff Bridges just has this awesome like
the shaved head and the end of B I'm
like man why can't my size be like that
I
have a Jeff Bridges beard that is badass
I had a much bigger beard and then I
shaved it as opposed to started this
movie just before we all went into
quarantine and I shaved it and then
they're like hey it's canceled Monica
what a waste of a beard it would have
been glorious right now ends want to
know are you guys in touch with your
cast mates have you been facetiming who
have you been texting with is there a
cast group chat that you guys have been
keeping up I talked to these guys on my
text Paul the other day just to see how
he's doing i text Pascale after she
after that I thought she was great and
with that what's that episode the windy
one the windy one where - she was very
and I said you killed it at the end and
she's like well what about the beginning
okay but the ending was great I know she
always makes us laugh but she absolutely
brought tears to my eyes in that moment
she saw what you guys are all so
talented okay so you've been in touch
Chris who have you been talking to Aaron
who you've been talking to yeah I mean
everyone I think we've got a lot of
different chats but there's there's like
a group chat that we check in on every
now and again and Pascale and I FaceTime
a lot when she picks up my calls
[Laughter]
she's probably asleep she wouldn't just
be screening my calls
I don't think Elizabeth rosemary well I
texted Kevin the other day I said hey I
was just thinking about you and then he
was fighting sick I was just about to
text you good god someone's been shot oh
we heard a gunshot in the promo and
we're all bent out of shape about it
what can you tell us uh what can we tell
you without giving anything away I mean
a gun is fired yeah well you could have
said it might have been a back firing of
the car exhaust maybe you think it's a
gunshot Lucas a gun do you it wasn't a
backfire Lucas was you know firing
something right let me ask you like this
Duke fans have to be worried that we
might have to say goodbye to somebody
that we love very much they should be
concerned okay a fan should should
always be worried I mean it's not quite
like as stressful as Game of Thrones but
it's true nobody's safe no David anytime
executive of our fans because I know
that everyone has a lot of PTSD from
when we lost Jack and so I don't want to
I don't want people to be afraid to
watch the season finale with their kids
I think that I think that it's safe to
watch with your kids in the room I'll
say that I just think in true when calls
the heart fashion the season finale is
going to feel epic and so everyone
should tune it
[Music]